Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're gonna share with
each other and with you,
our winter breaks.
What the heck happened
on our winter breaks?
Because we weren't together.
Something happened to you,
because you sound different.
You know, well yeah, I'll
kick it off with that.
I think that,
you know when we go on our breaks
and we do stuff separate that Ear Biscuits
is the place where we come back together.
Yeah.
And we share,
In fact,
we just give each other an update.
just a second ago, I was
telling you about something
that I was going to tell
you about and I was like
dropping my audio out,
as I was telling you,
so that I couldn't, that I
would wait to tell you now.
It's like,
I didn't notice, what do you mean dropping
your audio?
I was basically like saying,
"Yeah, so what's up?"
You know?
The equivalent would be like,
"And then the so and so
happened to the so and so."
You know?
Oh you were
Yes.
Editing yourself.
Right.
So that you
Yes.
Could tell me
for real is now?
Right.
Yeah, so that's what we're gonna do.
But, I do wanna say,
next week,
we're gonna start
Oh yeah, next week.
We're gonna start something that,
how would you even describe it?
I know, I don't--
What we're gonna do?
Well, yeah we're gonna devote
a number of episodes
to a topic that we've been,
just in the back of our minds,
there's been something
that's just been percolating,
for, maybe for years.
And I mean the thing that
we're gonna talk about for,
you know, it's been over,
for decades.
A lifetime.
A lifetime, decades.
We're gonna share about some stuff,
that we've never shared before.
With,
ever.
With any audience,
Publicly.
So we've decided that
we wanna talk about it,
here on Ear Biscuits next weekend.
2020, man,
Whoa boy!
I know that's just
a big tease, but,
It is a big tease.
That's what you gotta do
in this business, Link!
Man, I'm looking at my watch,
because I'm seeing if my
heart rate's going up.
I guess,
Hold on.
You know, I'm kind of
gathering my thoughts,
but, they're not
But you're
Fully gathering.
Heart rate
has gone up at weird times.
We were doing something the other day,
just like having a discussion
amongst like four people.
Yeah.
And all of a sudden,
you got your alarm,
and I was like, "What?"
Like,
I didn't even
say what it was, but you knew that it was
an abnormal heart rate?
Yeah, because I've, it's gone off before,
like.
I think it
has to do with what I'm dealing with.
So just to put a closer on the teaser,
and then,
Yeah.
I'll get back to the heart rate thing.
Yeah, so starting next week,
for a few episodes,
it's,
TBD.
It's something that we're gonna,
that we've made the decisions
we're gonna talk about.
And if, maybe even if I didn't,
if we weren't saying it right now,
we might even change our minds.
I don't think so.
No, no.
But now, we're definitely not.
No we are committed to this.
But first, let's catch up on our breaks .
I'm sick.
Now,
Really?
My freaking winter break,
has been bookended by sickness.
Two distinct types of sickness.
Now, the one that happened
on the front side,
I'm gonna wait to tell you about,
because it was just,
it was strange.
And I do know about that one,
because--
So strange.
It was so strange, you
couldn't not tell me about
that one.
Right.
And it's one of those things that like,
but you know what,
when I listen to you tell it,
I'm gonna seem like I've
never heard it before.
You don't have to do that,
but, it's yeah.
It was just so strange.
It's worth hearing twice.
Right?
Sure.
And this version will be
a little bit embellished,
because you've had time.
And then on the, if I can remember it.
I mean, I thought that it was
putting my vacation in
jeopardy and it was.
But then, I was able to go on my vacation,
which was, you know, enjoying the holidays
here in Los Angeles
with my immediate family
and then, we went to Mammoth Lakes.
Mammoth Mountain is at
Mammoth Lakes, right?
It's where you went last year,
to go skiing.
Usually,
I followed in
your footsteps,
Usually,
to Mammoth.
we Californians, just say Mammoth.
Well I went to Mammoth.
Amateurs who
have been there one time
say, "Mammoth Lakes."
And let's see, we came back on a Sunday
and then the previous Saturday,
my last day of skiing, I
came down with the sickness
that now, man I hope I'm getting over it.
I hope I'm not getting it,
at all.
But,
having come back to the office,
I've heard that a lot of people have had
this, I mean, it's just a head cold.
Some people have had like, bronchitis,
some people have had other things.
Christy had it before vacation.
And then Lando had it.
And then, I got, when Lando
was just getting over it,
dag gum it, he gave it to me!
Yeah, it makes you hate him, doesn't it?
And so now, and I will say,
it's like the worst head
cold I have ever had.
The worst sore throat I have ever had
in my life.
God I feel like
I need to wear like a mask.
And I didn't have a fever
and I'm almost positive
it wasn't strep throat.
I didn't go to see anybody,
because I'm stubborn.
But, and I did see gradual improvement,
but my throat was hurting so bad.
I mean it was like almost
in tears kind of like pain,
like,
That was probably
strep throat.
And then I was like, "You know what?"
Like a sore throat that is,
Let's go get Ramen.
That painful?
I better--
Is usually strep throat.
Better to make me feel better,
It does usually
To get Ramen.
resolve itself.
Well there was no fever.
And sometimes it turns
into a deadly disease.
Well,
That's what happens with strep.
I went and got Ramen and I said,
"You know what?
"Last time I got Ramen here,
"they called it spicy, but it wasn't.
"So make it a little more spicy."
Oh that was a mistake.
That was a mistake.
Like, and I ate the whole bowl,
but the first 15 minutes of eating,
like, it was like I was just,
I was in torture.
Come to find out, when you have like a
raw, sore throat,
you don't wanna eat spicy foods, y'all.
I don't know what I was thinking?
You wanna eat Ramen.
Ramen would've been
perfect.
Ramen, but non spicy!
Right.
Why did I ask
for it more spicy?
It was so stupid.
Man.
And like,
You know what Ramen is backwards?
Uh.
More Ramen, it's not, really.
It's close.
But it seems like
it would be.
If you would've
just said it was,
Right.
I would've believed
you.
It's almost.
My brain is, my head is
floating above my neck,
Yeah.
because it's
decongestive and I'm all I can't,
take advantage of me,
man, I can't think right.
It's actually, Namer.
Is what it is backwards, but.
Before we went
Close to no more.
To get Ramen,
I had like a Kombucha in the car,
because you know,
you've been talking about this Kombucha
you been drinking.
I been drinking
so much Kombucha.
I'm like, "I'm drinking a Kombucha."
And it made me feel,
I have a mother
better.
I have a mother in my stomach.
And I, that can happen.
That can happen.
I know, I want it.
You don't want that.
It's the only way I can give birth.
It's like .
A yeast ball.
You gonna, you gonna
crap out a yeast ball.
What a, you think that's gross.
What I'm about to tell
you is really gross.
Oh gosh,
great.
While I'm
drinking a Kombucha and I'm like,
"I think I should gargle with this."
And that was horrible too.
Like every, I think, all of my
instincts
You got a lot
Did nothing
of bad ideas.
But made it worse!
Yeah you started 2020 off
on the wrong foot, man.
With a lot of bad ideas.
Yeah and, I think I'm getting over it,
but this morning,
I got up.
And, you know, you're up for a few minutes
and things start to drain,
and start to settle and
like you can start to
breathe through your nose a little bit.
You hadn't been nettying any?
I did some Netti pottying.
I took Jade outside and
when I'm out there with her,
like I had walked down
the stairs out the front,
I got enough body movement that like,
there was some drainage and I like,
I hocked up a loogie,
okay?
Oh gosh.
And I'm outside waiting for her to pee,
and so I spit it out.
I'm sorry this is gross, but it's just,
it's what happens.
And I look down and it's,
Well it's what happens.
You don't have to tell,
listen, a lot of things
It was bloody.
Happened to me today, that
I'm not gonna tell you about.
Well I'm telling you it was bloody.
But I could tell by the
way that it came up,
that it was like,
it was a,
it was a weird consistency.
So I,
I bent down and I picked it up.
And it was,
What is wrong with you?
You know, if you've like,
if you like have a grape
and you like squeeze
the innards out of a grape
and all you're left with
is the skin of the grape?
That's what I spit up,
but it was blood colored.
I freaking spit up a scab,
the size of a grape.
That came out of my nose!
Like,
You had,
Somewhere in between,
like the back of my nose,
top of my throat, where
it was hurting the worst?
Apparently, I have a wound.
Yeah, you had strep throat, man!
Or something worse!
You wanna see it, I have it
right here.
No!
It makes me think of that,
Hold on, you took a picture of it?
No, I was gonna pull it out of my pocket,
the actual grape.
I'm sorry for grossing y'all out, but,
I actually feel a little better,
now that I've told you about it.
It made me think of that scene
in Buddy System Season 2,
where I burn your tongue with coffee,
and then you can no longer be
a professional food taster.
And but then at the end,
whenever I fail you, in the tournament,
you start talking funny
and you realized that your tongue scab
is coming off and you
pull like a big scab off
of your tongue?
That was so gross.
And we originally scripted
it so that when you
pulled the scab off of your tongue,
you were then gonna stretch it out
and tie it around your head
like a headband.
Yeah, yeah.
That was our,
that's what we scripted.
That was a little too gross.
And then we got notes that
it was a little too much.
Kind of like my story.
The tongue scab and it
was alone, was enough.
So I think I'm well on my way to recovery,
now that I spit out that scab.
Golly man!
You been hanging out with me all morning.
Yep, I wish you hadn't told me that.
I still feel like shit.
And I'm just, you know,
no bones about it.
Okay.
All right.
But I'm here.
I'm here for y'all.
Somehow I've avoided this and it just,
I just had this impending sense of doom,
because everybody's gotten sick
and I just haven't gotten sick
and I just.
Yeah, you'll get it.
Uh!
And you'll hate it.
Because it doesn't go away quickly.
It's miserable, man.
It's miserable.
Okay, well thanks for that, Link.
I feel like we can go home now.
I'm sorry.
You know?
I can't not be me.
And I just think there's
something to learn from that.
Well, but I'm gonna go
back to what I said, again,
I mean, I could describe
some like bodily things
that happen to me, today, this week,
that I just kind of I
keep to myself, you know?
I mean there's,
I appreciate you being vulnerable
and I appreciate you being open
about your experiences, but.
I mean things have come
out of me, as well.
It's one of those sicknesses
where--
But it's kind of
just between me and myself.
You know what I mean?
You know when you're in the worst of it,
you're like, "If I ever get better.
"When I get better, because I
believe I'm gonna get better,
"I'm gonna be so grateful
for feeling well.
You don't follow,
"I'm never gonna."
You don't follow my Twitter, apparently.
That's what this just represents.
Really?
Yeah.
You tweeted about this?
I tweeted this very
concept.
It doesn't work right?
Then you get well and you're like,
"Oh yeah, I'm just normal.
"There is no gratefulness."
Yeah and you think about
how grateful you're gonna be
when you're not sick,
when you're sick.
That's why
when I get home, I'm
gonna go find that scab
and I'm gonna take it inside
and it's gonna be a memento.
You're gonna take it for granted,
you're gonna take it for granted,
just like everybody does.
I'm gonna carry it around
in my pocket,
And then you get
sick again.
And I'm never gonna forget.
I'm never gonna forget.
How was your vacation?
Well let me see how many
loogies I hocked up.
It was great.
You know what,
actually,
You didn't get sick?
It was just kind of,
it was okay.
Yeah, I know man that's how I feel.
I'm gonna tell you all about my
okay,
I'm gonna tell you all
about my okay break.
But first, we're gonna
let you know that you can
Well that's a great teaser.
Get this,
Good Mythical Morning sweatshirt.
It's very, it's kind of cold
in this building right now.
It's 68 degrees outside.
But our office,
they've tried to get the heater working
and I know you're like,
"68, why is the heat on?"
Well because, it's like 40 in the morning.
And I want a little heat.
Well, we can't get any heat in our office.
No matter, you know,
If you want heat, go to mythical.com
and get yourself a,
And so I just,
I wear a hoodie.
Flame on a shirt.
I don't need heat.
There's a flame on the shirt.
And if you rub it,
it gets hotter and that's
the case with all shirts,
by the way, that's not a
special feature of this one.
But I made it seem like it was.
I'd say it's the case with everything.
It's just the case,
with everything that
you can buy,
with friction.
You can buy all types of
stuff at mythical.com.
If you rub any of it,
it's gonna get hotter.
Yeah, yeah.
We're gonna put that on the banner.
Rub it and it'll get hotter.
Our clothes, now with friction.
I mean we got all types, we got necklaces,
lip balm, rub any of it,
it's gonna get hotter.
That's true.
Rep your boys.
Mythical.com.
My,
What'd you do?
It's not,
it wasn't a vacation.
Can I just say that?
Because people,
You can say that.
people, people say,
"How was your Christmas vacation?"
Let's call it a winter break for you.
I'm like, and it wasn't
even much of a break.
Oh!
I don't know how to,
It was a break from work.
It was, but, I'm a workaholic, Link.
Oh.
Which is something
that I, which is something
that I already knew.
But, I typically have,
December rolls around.
Yeah?
And there's like a bunch of things
that sort of build up.
"Oh yeah, I'm gonna do that over break.
"Yeah, yeah, I'll do that over break.
"I'll do that over break."
And I had a list of things.
I didn't get to any of them.
I mean maybe like one thing.
And so,
actually,
And now you
feel bad about it and that's not right.
Well no, I had this,
I discussed this with my
therapist last night, actually.
I'll discuss it with you now.
But this sense of anxiety
that was building,
Yeah.
because I wasn't
getting to the things and I was like,
"Oh what's gonna happen is,
"break's gonna get over, be over,
"and then I'm gonna have all this stuff
"that I gotta go do right
at the top of the year
"and I don't wanna do that.
"And I'm anxious about it."
That's, I mean, yeah and
that's what happened to me
when I got back yesterday into the office.
That's why my watch went off.
My heart rate went through
the roof for a second.
Is we were just talking about something
that I felt like that we
were losing control of.
Well the thing that I
realized yesterday is,
when we had a conversation about it,
that's when I started feeling better.
Because it started feeling like,
"Okay, now things are actually happening
"and like, now people are saying,
"well I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna do this
"and you're gonna do this."
And it's like get some
Yeah, but what you did
Clarity came.
Which yeah,
you and I'm
No work was done.
I'm good.
Let me just
let me just be very clear.
No work was actually done.
It was just meetings.
I'm good at just pretending that
there's nothing to be done,
until you bring it up and gain clarity
and start to feel better.
What you're doing is you're transferring
all the stress to me.
That's what happened.
But, I also,
I love my family.
Let me be clear about this.
But when you are the one in the family
who has moved away and you come back,
you gotta see everybody.
Yeah.
And you gotta
see everybody kind of like
and your time ends up kind of
getting scheduled,
and it's not necessarily,
there's nothing relaxing about it.
It's not like going on a vacation,
is what I'm getting at.
And so it doesn't have the same sort of
emotional effect that a vacation has.
You going somewhere?
I just took my jacket off.
Don't let me distract you.
No, you're dressed like
you're going somewhere.
Oh!
You got an interview .
I thought if I put on a button up,
it would make me feel
better and seem less sick.
I'm freaking glassy eyed and tail droopy.
You know, I'm just trying,
I'm trying to muster some
sort of reason to go on.
If you are going to an interview,
I suggest a tie, just don't do that.
But,
Jessie and I did have a
little bit of a break.
So we, and of course we
were in North Carolina
for almost two weeks, seeing everybody.
And the good news is, that
everyone's close together,
so and I stay in the same place,
so it's like when you guys go back,
you have to go to all
these different places.
So we don't have to do that.
North Carolina.
But, we were there
like I said, almost two weeks
and then right after Christmas,
Jessie and I decided, well
we had already decided this.
We're gonna go get a little time away
and we're gonna go to Asheville.
Leave the kids with
which is like
Nashville
your parents?
Without an N.
And it's the place that
if you live in Los Angeles
and you say you're from North Carolina,
they're like, "Asheville?"
Like it's the only thing that people
know about North Carolina
in L.A. is,
Yeah.
"Asheville?"
Cool spot.
That's because it's super cool.
But no,
Mountains.
But you don't know
anybody who lives there.
But, it's a cool place to go.
That Grove Park Inn, that
big old historic hotel,
with the giant spa.
I got my massage on, et cetera.
You stayed there?
Yeah.
And,
brilliant plan!
You left the kids with like,
I don't even know.
Listen, I lost track
Cousins.
I'm not kidding.
I lost track of my children.
Both of them.
But they were in--
for multiple days.
They were under care of relatives.
I assume so!
Okay, well how was Asheville?
And I'm not joking about this.
Especially the 15 year old.
Like at one point, I saw him,
and then like six days later,
I saw him again.
Okay.
I was like,
"Are you brushing your teeth?"
Like I just,
"Are you taking care of yourself?
"Who's feeding you?"
Well I can guarantee he
looks better than you do.
I mean, you look like you rolled off a,
look at that, your hair, man.
Is every, when you went home,
did everybody have to say,
have to give an assessment?
Interestingly, no.
I think they just are a little worried.
Everybody just kind of no longer made
eye contact?
Yeah, they're just
a little worried and
Like caveman.
Won't mention it.
Yeah,
I mean even
when I saw you yesterday.
I was like, took my breath away.
I've lost, well thanks, Link.
I've lost a little control.
It actually has become,
it was a burden, I will say,
I don't wanna talk about
my hair at all, really.
But only thing I'll say is,
it has become a burden.
You'll fit in in Asheville.
We have gotten
Mountain men.
To burden stage.
It doesn't seem like
you're burdened at all.
And I thought that was the point.
It takes a lot of time to make
it look like I don't care.
Okay.
So, we went to Asheville
and you may remember from
and we had a great time.
You may remember, last year.
If you happened to be
A long time listener.
A student of my Instagram .
I'm, in 2020, I'm not gonna
use the term follower,
for any of my social media.
I'm just gonna use the term student.
And so, I got a belt with
my name on it last year.
This is what we're talking about.
Yeah.
Okay.
I remember that belt.
Jessie and I,
you've been
wearing that belt, all year.
Every single day.
With few exceptions, I wore that belt.
Okay.
With my name on it.
It hit me about November of last year,
"You know what, I should
do a belt again this year."
And then it was just like, "I
should do a belt every year.
"A belt every year
should be my new thing."
Do you know anybody else who does that?
Uh,
I saw someone,
I probably do, but they don't
think it's worth sharing.
I saw what they call some white space
in the belt every year, you know, area.
So, okay.
So, I thought I was gonna
go down to Olvera Street,
where the, that's where the
guy made my belt last year.
Here in L.A.
Not Asheville.
But, you know, I failed to do that,
because of all the stuff
we had to do and what not
and that I was anxious about.
Don't blame it
that I didn't
On me.
Actually do it.
And, but there was a
very fine leather shop.
I would give them a shout out,
but I already forgot the name.
Oh!
It's next to the Early Girl Eatery,
in Asheville, which is also
a really good place to eat.
Good spot, yeah.
Yeah, Jenna knows
about that, we ate there.
It was the pilot for
They got some biscuits, for,
Commercial Kings.
Well, couple doors down from that,
is this leather place and the dude has
a large assortment of
antique belt buckles,
along with all the
leathery that he will do,
I don't know if that's a word.
I didn't read many of the signs.
But I was like, "Hell yeah.
"I'm gonna get a belt buckle this time.
"Not just a belt.
"I'm gonna get a belt with my name on it.
"And a belt buckle."
Ladies and gentleman,
if you're watching this,
you'll have to wait, if you're listening.
But this is my new belt.
That's my new belt buckle.
Oh!
Look at that!
That,
Look at that.
Is a,
should I put
the microphone up to it?
Yeah.
If you wanna hear what it sounds like.
That's a wooden belt buckle.
with the dessert scene
on it.
Try not to show
any skin, tuck in your sweatshirt.
No.
Tuck in
the sweatshirt.
Huh, that's good.
Eh!
I got a little happy trail.
I'm gonna take it off and show it.
Because I'm gonna let you examine it.
Hold on this is,
Turning into a different kind of shoot?
This is bringing back flashbacks
of my babysitter's husband,
when he'd come home from work.
So this is a little bit,
He would just come home from work
and take off his belt.
This is a little bit different.
Now,
Paul Taylor Custom
Sandals and Belts?
Paul's Tailored Custom
That it?
Sandals and Belts,
sounds about right?
Custom sandals?
And belts.
So, now, you may remember.
This is, let me, can I
describe what I've seen,
because they're
Yeah, yeah.
Frustrated?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, what Rhett has
taken off from his waist,
Is a belt.
It is a warm belt.
Matter of fact, it's hot to the touch
on the back of the buckle.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a metal buckle.
I been thinking real hard.
And it's got wood in there.
Uh-huh.
I think,
or that could be jasper.
I think it's wood.
It's wood, man.
There's a Saguaro cactus,
I went to the wood section.
There is a freaking setting sun over the
Monument Valleyesque
That's it.
Desert formation.
It's a desert scene.
Mm-hmm .
On an oval belt buckle.
On a leather belt.
And let me tell you about
the design on the belt.
I can't remember the name
of this, what this is but,
I think it's called,
"Sage Brush."
It's called
tooling.
Now, last year, it was really haphazard
and he did it really quick.
This guy had to mail me this belt,
because he was like, "It's gonna take me
"you know, I can't finish this today."
Because this is like this thing
they like roll it through this thing
and it's got this it's
sort of this cactus theme,
but then when you get to the middle,
just check out what I did there.
It seems that Rhett has commissioned
the writing of something.
It's hard to see,
because it's in old,
Of the back.
It's in Old English.
But what does it say, Link?
Zarezo.
Zare, oh, no, no, no.
Z-O Rhett, Zo.
20,
Oh!
Yeah.
20 Rhett 20.
That's right.
I got a, I got a belt with
they year and my name on it.
Eh!
And that is what I'm
doing from here on out,
ladies and gentleman and then my kids
can fight over daddy's
belt collection when I die.
So it says 20 Rhett 20.
I'm not gonna give it to both of them.
What year is it?
20 Rhett 20.
In my will, it's going to say,
"A fight to the death between my sons,
"is how you determine who
gets the belt collection."
So when you die, you want one of your sons
To die.
To then also die,
for somebody to get your belt collection.
The son that loses the
fight, is buried with me.
With no belt?
It's so many belts, man,
just divide up the belts.
This is, let me tell
you right now, I didn't,
this belt got pricey real quick.
The one on Olvera Street, went 40 bucks.
I wanna know--
for a custom belt.
I don't even care.
I wanna know how much you paid for it.
Well you got, the thing
that gets it up there,
is the belt buckle.
Did he make that?
This belt buckle.
$79 for the belt buckle.
It's--
But it's a custom,
it's antique.
He just, he has these.
He found that from somewhere.
Some man wore this,
you know?
That's been on
some other man's pubic area,
for a long time.
Well just above it.
A man who wore this has like driven cattle
across expanses with Billy Crystal.
You know what I'm saying?
This is the real deal, man.
You don't know!
I like to believe it.
What was that guy's
name, a city slicker's?
Pappy, not Pap,
No!
Curly.
Curly!
Jack Palance,
right?
I think he won
an Oscar for that.
What a great movie.
Doesn't really hold up.
Or maybe he's
Watched it recently
with the kids.
Maybe he just came out,
during the Oscars.
Kind of holds up.
Anyway.
I'm not saying he was gay,
I'm saying he just appeared.
But he could also be gay.
I don't know or care.
But anyway, that was the
highlight for me honestly,
was getting a new belt.
I mean, I gotta say,
just to kind of put
It seems that
it was.
Things in perspective.
The best part of my Christmas break,
was getting a new belt.
And I feel a little naked without it,
but I'm gonna see how
if I can see without it.
Yeah, don't stand up,
because your pants will
stay where they are.
When we got back,
I felt like I needed a little
bit of an actual break.
And so, I went skiing.
In Big Bear, with Shepard,
I was gonna take--
You knew I was
had been skiing, and you felt like you
couldn't get left behind.
Oh, if that's how you wanna see it.
The way I saw it was,
we're going skiing as a family,
and we're going to
Mammoth, in the near future
and it's like, you kind
of wanna get your ski legs
back.
Yeah, yeah.
But Lark and I were
going actually to Mammoth
with friends and so, and got a concussion.
And had to not ski.
Long story.
He's fine.
But so,
Wow.
Shep and I just went, just the two of us.
Skied for a couple days.
Had a great time.
I did see that on your story,
because I was back in the real world then,
being sick and doing
nothing except bedridden,
looking at you galavanting
down the mountain.
Really trying to see if you
could ski better than me,
is what I was trying to assess,
having gone for five days, in Mammoth.
I think I could probably
ski better than you.
Okay.
I've just I've got a lot
more skiing experience.
I was--
That is true,
but I don't think,
my whole spring break
You can.
Last year.
Yeah.
Was six days of skiing.
You wanna have a ski off?
Ski off, done.
Where?
Well that kind of
brings me to my--
Name a time
and place.
My thoughts
about skiing, which it had been two years
since I had been skiing,
really for the first time,
in a long time, when I along with the kids
were trying to learn how to ski.
Do you do the Black Diamonds?
And given up the snow boarding.
Hell no, I don't do
the Black Diamonds.
Well then I'm
better than you bro.
Are you telling me you
can ski a Black Diamond?
If it's not moguls.
Hell yes.
Well then you're
definitely better than me.
I mean,
because I mean,
I went up to a blue,
I don't look like
I know what I'm doing, but I'm fine.
I mean,
I went up
to a blue,
There's a lot of
sliding going on,
not a lot of real skiing.
And here's what I thought.
Here's what struck me, because,
I was like, "Christy do
you wanna come ski with us,
"like we're learning,
we'll have an instructor."
And she was like, "No."
She basically said,
"You know, it's scary."
And I was like, "Okay, I respect that."
And then,
That's what's
fun about it.
I got back,
I got out there and with the kids
and we were all doing well, like,
being instructed and
really getting back into it
after a couple of years.
But it, the thing that struck me,
I was seeing like old people.
I was seeing people who were like,
rotund, like not really
people in shape, okay?
Yeah, because you're sliding.
And,
The bigger the better,
I think.
But here's the thing.
Skiing is an extreme sport.
You're going down a
mountain on two sticks.
And, for some reason,
anybody thinks they can roll up,
rent some crap and do it.
And then there's,
and I don't know how,
old people and out of
shape people are doing it.
I consider myself kind of in shape.
In shape enough at my age,
to like, get out there and look all right.
But like,
maybe I have a heightened
sense of mortality,
or I have an appreciation
where there's a lot more
riding on me now, you know?
Your entire career, buddy.
Okay.
For one .
So, it is scary.
I mean, you're freaking on the
side of a mountain on sticks.
Well, I will--
It's an extreme sport.
Well no, no.
It's not, no, no,
You wouldn't--
no, no, it's not an
extreme sport.
You wouldn't--
Certain,
the ski jumping is an extreme sport.
Skiing--
Skiing is an
extreme sport!
No it's not!
It's a winter sport!
If you would go to the top of the mountain
in the summer time with
a mountain bike.
Ice skating,
ice skating is not
an extreme sport.
Like I said,
you don't wanna mountain bike down this.
There's no way anybody could just,
it's like, "Well I've
ridden a bike before.
"Okay, zoop, zoop, zoop,
I'm going down a mountain."
No!
Well hold on, but see no.
You can, it's all on a spectrum.
I could go down a mountain bike course,
at a very slow speed.
I couldn't do it in a
way that is respectable
or actually sporty.
But I could brake my way down it.
Well this is and speaking from experience.
Now I think I talked about this years ago,
when I had my accident
on like a downhill mountain bike course,
is that that's not actually true.
If you get to a certain steepness,
like the, a double Black Diamond,
or a Black Diamond of mountain biking,
you actually, the slower you go,
you're screwed.
Well, but--
You gotta bank
the curves.
But with the skiing.
Listen, if you get to a place,
I don't do the,
I do the Black Diamonds, occasionally,
when it's like, oh when you
kind of need to go down this
really quick Black Diamond
to get to this other blue
and it's not moguls.
Moguls is bad news for me.
I'm big, I got big skis.
I don't like to turn
But even in the turns.
Really fast.
The thing about a turn,
is that, in order to ski properly,
you have to commit and shift your weight
forward down the hill and all
instinct tells you to do is,
the steeper it gets, lean back more.
Which immediately causes trouble
and you're zooming down the mountain
and you could die.
You have to trust the technique,
at least in my understanding,
to shift your weight forward,
over the leading ski,
or the outer ski and then make a turn.
And that is a scary moment.
Like when I was on a blue.
Well it's very scary,
until--
I did it.
But I was--
It's very scary.
Wigging out.
Until, you develop the feel
to be like, "Oh, I can
turn both ways, reliably."
And once you can turn and stop yourself,
then you can pretty much do anything.
Again, I'm not saying I look
like I know what I'm doing.
It's not like I,
Yeah.
I've got good form
and I'm not carving.
I'm definitely kind of sliding and,
let it be known,
I'm thinking about not getting hurt,
the entire time.
It's not like when I was a young man
and I was just thinking about,
"What the most fun thing
that I could do right now?"
Yeah, yeah.
And,
"What's the most fun line
"that I could take down this mountain?"
It's very much like,
"How can I not get hurt?
"Is that way less hurt?
"Is this way less hurt?"
Well to me, that's not going
above a blue.
Well, but you gotta,
you still gotta have a little fun.
And once you get, there doesn't seem to be
any difference, steepness,
is no longer becomes an issue,
when you can turn without any trouble.
And that is sort of,
I don't get that, yet.
You'll get there in like
two more days of skiing.
You know what, you come out with me,
I'll show you .
I mean who,
has anyone taught you how to
do like the plant the pole
and turn thing?
Like the proper technique for?
I watch,
you know the people
with the full ski suits.
Oh yeah.
Like one piece?
That dude knows what he's doing.
Even though you can like get one that says
U.S. Ski Team on Amazon.
I just assume if you've got one of those,
you know what you're doing.
And--
I'm gonna get
one of those just so people can say,
"You'll never believe what happened.
"I got run over by a guy from the
"U.S. Ski Team."
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"He was totally out of control.
Yeah, he must have been,
"He was
"amazing."
The equipment manager.
No, yeah, I can do it,
but it's, yeah, it doesn't
look smooth and cool
and like pop, like
the guys.
I wanna get there,
because I think there's a zen
associated with like,
going up high,
I mean I was at Mammoth the
whole time with my kids,
and like we didn't,
we only went on a blue once.
You missed so much of the mountain.
I know, but I just,
I didn't have the technique.
Green--
And I didn't
wanna ditch my kids.
Here's the problem.
Here's the problem with the greens.
Too many people.
In fact, when you go to Big Bear,
there's, the summit, the snow summit,
which is the,
Yeah.
Sort of the bigger
mountain between the two,
you can do there.
There's this really long
run called Summit Run.
And it's green the whole way
and it gets carved up by all these people
and there's just kids and,
it's like,
Old people?
Yeah, but what we found is,
there's a certain part of the mountain
if you go off sort of, it's
far to the left as you can get,
you come down these long blue runs
and then you get back on the lift
and literally there's no line.
Yeah.
And like, the people are an obstacle.
We should go, man.
My boys are getting
there.
Ski off.
Lily's done great, but she doesn't really,
she doesn't, she's not motivated
to get up the mountain.
But the three of us are.
One of the things that,
I'll go with you.
When is that?
In a couple weeks?
Am I now invited ?
Well no, we've already kind
of got things worked out.
We're going with a different family
.
I thought
he invited me, guys.
Eh, right.
Did you hear that?
Yeah.
He was like,
"Come with me."
You know ski off
And then I knew
he was going.
Is anytime, any place.
Except, the predetermined
time that I'm going skiing
with another family .
Okay, yeah, you don't
want me to embarrass you,
I get it.
Jessie,
when we were in Asheville.
When we travel together,
Jessie watches trashy reality TV.
It's just what she does.
We don't really watch it any other time.
Okay.
And we have like TLC and Bravo, like,
you know, at home, but I
don't know if she knows that.
And I plan
to keep it that way.
I think she thinks
that TLC and Bravo, only
get broadcast in hotels.
Okay.
Hope she doesn't--
I can't--
Good thing she doesn't
listen to this podcast.
I can't tell you what's on that.
What did you watch?
Well on TLC.
Isn't that The Learning
Channel?
The Learning Channel,
yeah, Link, no one's
learned anything on TLC
for many years.
Okay.
Except how to not behave.
You know, how to not be like the people
in all the shows that they have.
Okay.
But um,
Like the housewives
show?
The one in particular
that we watch, is 90 Day Fiance.
You guys know about this?
Mm-mm.
There's a show where,
well, Jessie made fun of me,
and tweeted this out because,
I was watching it kind
of over her shoulder,
I get sucked in.
I'll admit, I get sucked
into these things.
And they go through a
number of different couples.
And I was like,
is it always, is one of
them always international?
And she like thought that was so funny,
she had to tweet it.
Because the whole point of the show is,
yes, it's someone who's getting married,
essentially to get a Green Card.
Oh.
It's not that the love isn't real, but.
And then they only
have to be married
But the pretense is,
For three months?
Well, I don't know,
What's the three months?
Because I think you have to be,
I think you have to be
is it married for?
I don't know where the 90 days comes in.
You have to be engaged
for at least 90 days?
Like you can't be in
Apparently it doesn't
matter,
a relationship
for 90 days to enjoy it.
Yeah.
What did you,
what was your take away?
If it wasn't that?
My take away was, I
learned a lot about myself.
Because I ended up
tweeting something like,
"Sometimes I start to think
that I'm a good person
"and then I realize that
I am ruthlessly judging
"a woman I don't know
for serving pizza rolls
"at her wedding."
Now with the tweet that I wanted to tweet,
that Jessie said, "No
you can't tweet that."
Was, "Sometimes, I start
to think that I might be
"a good person and then I
start having murderous impulses
"towards a woman that I don't know,
"for serving pizza rolls at her wedding."
So you wanted to kill somebody.
Yeah, that's what I wanted to talk about,
is that, when I watch these people,
But you like pizza rolls!
What a hypocrite!
No one even served pizza
rolls at their wedding.
It was the kind of thing
that would have happened
on the show.
It was a joke.
Okay, okay.
I found myself wanting to hurt the people
on the show.
And?
Just like, I was like, "Where is this
That doesn't sound like
"coming from?"
Entertainment to me.
Man, somebody who's got so many opinions
about the way people behave,
you watch one of these freaking episodes,
and you tell me you don't
wanna kill these people!
I'm not, I'm saying,
I probably would, but I
wouldn't spend my time
trying to be entertained
in that manner.
You just,
you just watch it, and you're like,
you can't, it's like train wreck.
You can't look away.
You just can't, but I can't believe,
some of the decisions that people make.
Oh, but you know what?
That tweet that I actually made.
That was different.
I've got my,
This show is
rabbit hole,
Not about you rehashing all your tweets,
man.
No no, no no.
The thing that I was
actually tweeting about was,
Four Weddings, which is a different show.
I wanted to kill those people too,
just to be clear.
Four Weddings?
This is when four women have a wedding.
They each have a wedding.
They're all getting married,
but they attend each other's weddings,
as the show and then they
rate each other's weddings
and then the winner, the best wedding,
from the other three women deciding
who has the best wedding,
gets like a trip,
a honeymoon, or something.
So the women are horrible to each other.
And I wanted to kill three
out of four of those women.
Okay.
Not, there was one that was like, "Okay,
"she can go."
But you wanted to keep watching?
I couldn't stop.
It sounds unhealthy.
But I couldn't
stop hating them.
I was just like, "I can't do this.
"I can't watch this.
"These people make me so mad,
"for the dumb things, the
decisions that they're making."
Is that, I mean is
Jessie feeling that way?
Why does she watch it?
The same reason anyone watches
any reality television.
Yeah, I mean, of course--
She doesn't get angry.
It's just like I watch the Bachelor too.
You know?
But she gets a kick out of it.
She's not getting angry.
I don't know, maybe she's got,
she's better than me.
Well we know that.
She's, no, she's getting a kick out of it,
but you know, you just get so frustrated
with people sometimes,
and you're just like,
"I just don't understand how this person
"got to be this person."
I thought that they were
supposed to make you,
these shows, feel better about yourself.
But it's interesting that it's making you
come to grips with the fact
that you are a bad person.
Yeah, because I think you
could just watch them,
and just be like, "Well I'm
better than that person.
"Oh I'm better than that person.
"I'm better than that person.
"I'm glad I'm not that person.
"I'm better than that person."
Which, would be a pretty easy thing to do.
But, instead, it turned
into murderous impulses.
I wouldn't actually do it,
but I just found it.
I felt it in my heart.
And wanted to tweet it,
but then my wife said I couldn't.
But now I have.
And then I told her--
I don't tweet
on vacation, because I'm on vacation.
Tweets' work for me.
But I did, in my draft,
in my drafts,
Yeah, the murderous
drafts.
It just says,
"Murderous impulses."
In a draft.
Okay.
On Twitter.
Okay, okay.
Because I was like,
"I gotta go back to that,
"that's a good one.
Get rid of
that.
"People will like
"that."
Get rid of that.
It did remind me that,
last year, when we went to Sedona.
At night, you may recall,
we would watch Survivor.
Having never watched it,
we as a family got into watching Survivor.
So my plan and everybody was on board was,
that we were gonna do
that again this year.
Oh good.
It was an interesting dynamic though
that like, Lily's 16 years old.
She had a friend who was also in Mammoth.
So like the first night,
she was like, "Can I spend
the night with my friend?"
And like,
No, you have
to stay here and watch
Survivor with your family.
Yeah, so I was like, "Yes tonight,
"you can be away."
You know, so it's like,
we're in this weird flux as a family,
where it's like,
You can't
you can't hold it together.
You can't.
I can't
hold it together,
You can't.
All the time.
Yeah.
So you choose
your battles.
Yeah.
That went out the door,
but what we did do,
in the wake of the Rise of Skywalker and,
something about Harrison
Ford made a connection
to Indiana Jones and I
think Christy was like,
"We should watch Indiana Jones."
Because the kids hadn't seen it.
And so,
What?
They hadn't seen Indiana Jones.
Any of them.
I have, okay?
Wow.
Of all the things
I haven't seen,
I have and I got a
special place in my heart
for the second one, Temple of Doom,
because, it is the first movie
I ever remember watching in the theater.
Mm-hmm .
You know, I'd visit my dad,
I had visitation with my
dad, or whatever you call it.
He was not in prison though.
What's it call when you
don't live with your dad,
and then you have to go stay with him?
Hanging out.
Yeah.
I was hanging out with my dad.
There is a name,
I don't know.
It's not custody.
What's that name, I don't know.
Anyway.
It might be
visitation, you might be right.
But it just sounds like,
you're visiting a prison,
a person in prison.
I mean this was,
I think it was 1983,
when this movie came out.
Can you check that?
I guess, I mean,
maybe it was four.
Temple of Doom?
Yeah.
I mean it could've been,
even if it was '86,
I would've been eight years old.
It was the first movie
I saw in the theater
and I was,
he wanted to see it and I guess he thought
I would like it, but I was terrified.
'84.
So, yeah.
I was six years old.
Because of the heart scene?
Yeah and the dude reaches in there
and pulls out a beating heart.
It scared the crap out of me.
But it was special.
And I wanted to share that with my kids,
especially Lando, who I
told him to close his eyes.
So we watched all four of them.
And let me tell you, the first
three are freaking magical.
The fourth one, it had Shia LaBeouf
and you know I'm really into him now.
Right, but--
Big fan of his.
But you're into Shia,
Big fan of him now.
LaBeouf.
Right now.
Fully matured.
Not like,
you know.
Too much CGI.
Teen Shia LaBeouf.
The first three are,
I think Temple of Doom's my favorite.
But, we had a blast watching these
and it's the first two are just,
they're all amazing.
I mean, I think they're you know,
my favorite movies and I was just
reminded of that.
Your favorite movies
and your kids hadn't seen them until now?
Yeah.
What have you been doing?
It was fun, man.
It's fun watching that.
But, yeah so that,
that was the big thing for me
and I think, you know,
coming back, I'll tell you this story
that I gotta tell you the medical story,
before I went.
But just concluding,
because I kind of feel
the same way you do,
in terms of like,
last night I told Christy, I was like,
"You know, now that we're
back from our vacation,
"what do we think about it?
"What did we learn?
"What do we wanna do
differently next year,
"because this is our second year of being
"in L.A. for Christmas."
And the thesis is we're
building our own traditions
and you know, I had this feeling of like,
like you said at the top.
You're like, "It was you know, it was."
I always want it to be great.
And be like the best Christmas ever,
but it was, like it was okay.
But then the more we thought about it,
I realized, we actually
started to talk about
and I wonder if you and
Jessie ever talk about this.
It's like,
as the kids get older,
we wanna start building
expectations and traditions.
Things that we are gonna keep doing.
There's an expectation, so that,
when they go off to school.
They'll go off to their own lives
and they're starting to
date people and get engaged
and whatever they're gonna do
that they're gonna wanna come back
and do these things with us every year.
So it's like, "Okay this is
what we do for the holidays."
And after the holidays, we
would always take a trip,
you know, we've done
it two years in a row.
It doesn't really matter
how great the trip is,
as long as there's an
expectation that like,
especially when kids start leaving,
I was like, "Man, I'm sure
it will be special when
"Lily's been off at college
and then she comes back
"and like, the boys haven't seen her
"since she went to college.
"Like she didn't come home
for Thanksgiving say."
You know we got--
Where is she going?
She's like further away at college,
kind of like, you know,
our friend's daughter,
who like, went up to Oregon.
Right.
And like
they didn't see her until,
her sibling didn't see
her until she came back
for Christmas.
And I'm like,
"Yeah and if we're just at home,
"you know what's gonna happen.
"Oh I got these plans here.
"I got these plans here."
But like if we have this expectation
that we're doing some sort of family trip.
I'm like, "I think this
can become really special
"in that way."
So I started to feel better about it.
Then like, Lily and
Lincoln have left the house
and like, it's just Lando waiting around.
It's like, "Hey I haven't
seen my siblings in months."
And then they're coming back
and we're doing something.
And I started to feel like,
"You know what?"
As I often conclude about myself.
I put so much pressure on the specifics,
you know and achieving
some sort of perfection,
that it actually made
me feel better to say,
"Okay, we're creating space."
And I think I've said this before.
"Creating an opportunity
for memories to be made."
And I think that's the biggest victory.
And that's the definition of success.
If we're together enough,
where things, good, bad,
different can happen,
that's success.
Especially for when they get old and,
Oh so all you gotta do
to get them to come back,
when they're old, is go somewhere,
because they won't have any money.
Yeah, that's right.
And when you say, "Hey, free trip.
"Your meals will be paid for."
These kids are gonna come back, man.
They'll be coming back
for years.
"Can I bring
"my girlfriend?"
They'll be
coming back for years.
"Can I bring my boyfriend?"
Now if you just say, "Hey,
just come back to the house."
You gotta, you gotta,
you gotta have a carrot.
That's what I'm building.
Indiana Jones, Survivor.
Well.
Well before you tell your medical story,
Sure.
I wanna run something by you,
that happened to me on the flight back.
Okay, you wanna cough drop?
Uh, nope.
And I don't wanna touch anything
that you've been touching.
All right.
So, .
Coming back on the flight.
You know, it's like a five hour flight.
Five, six hour flight from Raleigh to L.A.
And I got this new
neck pillow thing and
I'm experimenting with.
Because me and Lark are
taking a very special trip,
that I'm not even gonna tell you about it,
until I get back from it because,
it's a pretty big moment for me.
Oh!
But it requires a long flight.
And,
I was like, "I wanna be able to sleep
"on the plane."
That's months
from now.
Yeah, I need to figure out
how to sleep on the plane,
so I'm gonna test some pillows.
I don't like the regular ring,
the regular donut pillow.
I don't like the fact that
there's a pillow behind my neck
and I fall all around.
There's this thing, I
don't even know what it is.
Where you, it's a brace,
inside of a blanket
and then you wrap it around your neck
and then it,
it Velcros back onto itself.
And so, you're, it's this piece of plastic
is basically supporting your head
and it got all these
reviews on Amazon like,
five star reviews on Amazon.
You talking about a scarf,
It's a scarf with a
with a wedge in it.
Built in brace.
Okay.
And, it kind of worked.
I still ended up waking
up and thinking like,
"My neck doesn't feel
great, but better than if
"I had one of those traditional pillows."
Anyway, so I like slept through
the flight attendant coming by and asking,
"Do you want a snack and do
you want a drink or whatever."
Uh-huh.
So I wake up,
and she's like walking by
and I was like, "Oh, oh, oh, excuse me.
"Could I get one of the
protein boxes and a water?"
Like this is like the pay,
like you have to
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pay for it, right?
She's like, "Okay."
So then, another flight
attendant comes back.
And she hands me the protein box.
And I was like, "Thank you,
"oh and could I also get a water?"
Mm-hmm .
And she said,
"I've only got two hands."
Oh snap!
Whoa!
"I've only got two hands?"
What?
This is not even the same person?
It was a different person.
And it's like, "Okay."
And before I could be like, I'm not,
first of all, there
are certain people who,
like my brother, is an example.
Yeah.
He would
immediately clapped back.
Yeah.
But I was just like, "Oh okay."
And then,
so then, Jessie,
hears this interaction and she's like,
"What was that?
Why, well you didn't do anything wrong."
And then, and first of all,
you could carry a water and
a protein box with two hands.
Just FYI.
Yeah, because one of them's a box,
And one of them's a cup.
Well, or a bottle.
So I,
Jessie then goes, gets
up to go use the restroom
and then she comes back and she says,
"You will not believe what just happened."
What happened?
She's like, "That flight
attendant was back there,
"telling another flight attendant about
"the interaction that
she just had with you."
What?
"And she was saying, "And
then he says, "Could I get
"a water?" And I was like,
"I've only got two hands."
And I was like, "What is happening?"
Like,
That's weird!
And I was, I don't,
I hope that's not the end of your story!
It is,
man!
Oh no!
I don't know what
happened!
Come on,
because, let me finish your story.
So then, I got up to "use the bathroom."
But when I went up there
and I saw the woman,
I said, "Excuse me, ma'am.
"My wife just overheard,
"you retelling the story,
"that I was also talking to my wife about.
"and we can't make sense of the fact
"that you're so upset
that I asked for a water.
"After you deliver me a box.
"It seems totally reasonable to then ask
"for you to go back and get a water."
And I'd already asked for a water.
"Even though I already
Well to another
"Asked for one."
to another flight attendant.
"So what did I do wrong?
"What can I do differently next time,
"so that you won't come
back and spill the tea,
"to your comrades up here at the front?
The problem--
"I'm baffled!"
The problem with that kind of behavior,
is that, that's the kind
of the thing that like
escalates quickly and
the next thing you know,
somebody,
They're turning
the plane around.
Like a,
like a U.S. Marshall like
sticks a syringe in your neck
and you fall down.
Like you know what I'm saying?
Like,
Yeah.
It's like, that's the kind of thing
that happens when you,
Because if anybody,
when you rebel
on an airplane.
If anybody
puts you on a, like a phone video,
they're like, "That dude is crazy."
Right!
Look at his hair!
Yeah and so I was just like,
I let it slide.
I mean the other woman did bring me water
and it was great.
I'm angry.
Good, I wanted to set,
I feel,
I wanted you to
get angry,
I feel
before you told your last story.
I feel murderous thoughts!
There you go!
Now we're talking!
I feel like murdering,
Welcome to 2020!
this woman, who's just gonna be,
she only wants to be engaged for 90 days
so she can, I don't know,
for some sort of citizenship thing.
And that's not even the right show!
Pizza rolls!
I'm confused.
So a few days before,
the holidays really start getting going,
hold on.
No this was the day after Christmas,
because two days later,
we were gonna go to Mammoth.
And I wake up, y'all,
I think it was before Christmas.
Because I remember talking to you
Christmas Eve.
Was it?
Yeah, that's right.
It was the Christmas Eve eve.
I did the thing I rarely do,
which is, talk to you over break.
Because you heard
Because I was--
something happened to me.
Because I was concerned.
And you asked me.
I think Jessie asked you,
told you to ask me.
No she didn't!
To have
some sort of empathy.
No your wife texted Jessie,
Yeah.
And said something that was strange
about your health situation
and I called you,
you know, 90 minutes later
.
Not on your
own volition though.
You know what?
I'm glad that you asked me,
how I was doing and I'm sorry
that I assumed that your
wife put you up to it.
Good.
Is that really how it happened?
It is how it
happened!
Okay, cool, cool,
.
Tell your story, man.
So whatever freaking day it was,
I'm in a murderous frame of mind now, man.
It's your fault,
if I'm coming down on you.
If I'm taking it out on
you, it's your fault.
Yeah.
I woke up, because,
the room was spinning.
I didn't wake up and find
that the room was spinning.
I woke up because,
with my eyes shut,
I was tumbling through some sort of space.
I open my eyes and I'm laying on my side
and, the room is spinning at this rate.
Wow.
What miles per hour, if
you're on a carousel,
it's like,
if a kid's on one of those merry go rounds
and an adult is running
as hard as they can,
pushing it around, and you're the kid.
That's fast.
Fast!
But it depends on how big it is.
What the radius of the merry go round?
Yeah.
The centrifugal acceleration,
is dependent on the radius.
Not if you're sitting in the
middle of the merry go round.
You're right about that.
All right!
So, I wake up and it's like,
I didn't have anything to
drink the night before.
I just, this was no
hangover type of a spin.
And, I sat up
and I just sat there and
as I was sitting there,
I'm slowly falling over, on the bed.
Because you know, it's just
like if you get real dizzy,
you can't sit up straight.
And then finally I got still enough
that the room did stop.
And, I had slept later than Christy,
she wasn't even up there.
So I got my phone and I was like,
"I need you to come up here,
"because I feel weird."
But I had to pee really badly.
So then I got up and I
slowly walked to the toilet.
And I sat down to pee.
Not because I always sit
down to pee, which I do.
But because I really had to this time.
And ,
I basically fell off the toilet,
because the room started to spin again.
Hmm.
And then Christy came up there
and I told her, well actually,
I made my way downstairs,
because she never got the text
and I'm like explaining
to her what happened,
because, it would just go into a spin
and but it wasn't constant.
It was like at certain times.
So I got, I made my way
down there just fine
and I'm like telling her,
and she's like, "Well
I got up this morning
"and I was really sick."
Do you have a Google Home?
Because you can broadcast
to the whole house.
Yeah, I do.
So I could like do an intercom thing,
like, "Help me, the room is spinning!"
Yeah, you say, I'm not
gonna say the thing,
"H, Google."
Uh-huh.
Broadcast, "Help me,
the room is spinning!"
Okay.
And then it'll do that.
I do it all the time.
I'll do that next time,
because then hopefully,
somebody would've come running.
And she was like,
"Well I was really sick
this morning, like,
"it wasn't good.
"I think I have food poisoning."
I'm like, "You know what?
"I guess that's."
We ate the same thing.
The kids ate something different.
I just, we thought I had
food poisoning somehow.
I like google like dizziness
associated with food poisoning.
You can find some link to anything.
So like, thought that's what it was.
It happened
a few more times.
That's some
serious food poisoning.
I know, I just went back and I was like,
"I'm gonna go back and lay down in bed."
And when I laid down,
it happened a little
bit, but I went to sleep
and I woke up with the room spinning,
same thing happening again.
Christy starts talking to
a friend of hers, Katie,
who's like, "You know, Link's got vertigo!
"A lot of my relatives have it.
"You should try," she
mentioned some maneuver,
which later, it turns out was something
called the Epley Maneuver.
So we're like googling this thing.
It actually was the next day
that we had this conversation with her.
We didn't uncover this maneuver.
You had a day of spinning.
I had a day of spinning and a night of it.
Gosh!
And I was like looking up
canceling my reservations
at Mammoth, like, I was thinking,
"When do I start getting penalized,
"if I cancel now versus cancel later.
"How much more is it gonna cost me?"
Because I'm like, "There's
no signs of this going away."
You could have been the guy
who just spins down the mountain though.
And we were googling a bunch of stuff,
but then the next day,
when we googled this.
It was so interesting.
It was like, "Okay, I'll give."
This is a maneuver that you
can just try on your own.
There's like physical therapists who have
YouTube videos that tell you how to do it.
But the theory behind it is,
in your inner ear,
which of course is a
center of equilibrium,
along with like parts of your brain.
You've got these,
if you've seen the model of the inner ear,
you've got these different loops
that come off of it, right?
These like different tunnels,
which are filled with,
I don't know, I'm gonna call it liquid.
I believe it is.
And it's these different tubes that come,
that are oriented in different directions
that magically in both your ears keep you,
it's miraculous, when
you look at how this,
these mechanisms work.
And then, the assertion is that,
if a crystal, which
apparently there are crystals
in another part of your ear,
that are supposed to be there.
If a crystal,
We're not, not New Age crystals.
No, just like a particle.
Not like something that Gwyneth Paltrow
would insert in her vagina?
Like a, not a, no.
Not a goop dildo.
I don't know.
Okay.
I'm talking about,
what they would call a crystal,
makes his way into one of these canals,
where it is not supposed to be.
Oh!
Then every time that
crystal moves in the canal,
the room starts spinning.
That's crazy.
And,
I was like, "This is wild!"
Do you grow these crystals as an adult?
Or like they're there as a baby?
I don't understand.
I don't.
They seem to imply that,
the crystal got in the wrong place.
Not that the crystal existed.
And these are in the few
videos that I watched, okay?
I only wanna know how to fix it.
I didn't really care about,
Do I have crystals?
Reading their Wikipedia.
Yes!
I just wanna make sure I've got crystals.
It, this Epley Maneuver is wild,
because, it's a series of movements,
that then manipulate the crystal to
go on a nice little
trajectory around the loop.
Using gravity.
Using gravity to then exit,
the canal, that tunnel.
Man, this feels like
the kind of thing that,
Hoo doo.
You watched a YouTube video.
Yeah.
And you do it.
I got really excited.
And you know,
And like, "This ain't gonna work."
You know while it's happening.
When you see the thing
being performed on someone,
you're like, "This is not going to work."
Especially when it's this simple.
Okay.
You sit up on your bed
and then you lay down
such that then your head is tilted back.
Like, if I'm sitting up here straight,
I'm gonna look up, like
put my chin in the air.
So that my head is angled back.
Mm-hmm .
And then you,
you lay back and then you
tilt your head to the right.
Or the, depending on which ear it's in.
I'll just say, I don't
even know which is which,
but like, you turn to the right 45 degrees
and then look back 30 degrees,
or something like that.
Did you have a protractor?
And then, no.
No protractor.
Did you have a
protractor?
Christy was there
like holding my head, because
I showed her the video.
Excuse me, I thought I had another scab.
Oh gosh!
So you lay back.
You look in this one direction.
And the room starts to spin.
You hold it, until the
room stops spinning.
What, really?
Yes.
And that did happen?
And that happened just a little bit.
The room moved just a little.
Half spin.
And then, there's three positions.
The second position is,
instead of looking to
the right 45 degrees,
with your head still tilted back,
then you turn your head,
to the opposite, looking
45 degrees to the left.
Head still draped over the end of the bed.
I know, this may not make sense,
but you can watch the YouTube video.
Then the room starts to spin again.
I.e. the crystal has moved.
And you have to let the room stop spinning
so the crystal can settle
in this new position.
Crystals, man.
And then the third one is,
while you're looking to the left,
then you take your whole body
and you roll over on your side,
while keeping that same
angle, 45 degree angle,
of looking to the left.
So now you're looking
straight down at the floor
and laying on your left side.
What is your wife doing at this point?
She's turning me over and trying to like,
take the vantage point of like,
yes, she's my protractor.
Are you both naked?
We're both naked,
yes.
We're making love,
while this is happening.
I forgot that part.
You need to be in a constant state
of love making.
No!
Right, that's how you
get that crystal moving.
Yeah, .
Yeah, yeah, lots of crystals
moved.
Yeah.
When I turned over to that third position,
the world unhinged.
What?
It was spinning so aggressively.
This is,
I started,
Now I want this to happen
to me .
I started,
it was so scary dude.
Hey, I simultaneously felt encouraged
because something was happening.
Because it was going according to
It was going
to plan.
According to plan.
And the room was spinning so aggressively,
that I started moaning uncontrollably.
I was like,
Oh wow!
Oh!
Those are the noises
I was actually making.
Wow!
Oh!
And I thought I was going to vomit.
Wow!
It was so bad.
And it took way too long for my taste,
for the room to stop spinning,
but you have to
hold it.
You have to
wait for the crystal.
And then you sit up
and, on the edge of the bed,
and this one particular
YouTube video I saw,
which no one else afterward,
told me that I had to do this,
but the physical therapist
in this video was like,
"And then at this point, make
sure for the next 24 hours
"that you don't look up."
And so, he recommended that,
Yeah.
You put on a neck brace.
Yep.
And I wanted to follow
everything to a tee.
I didn't have a neck brace.
So I took a towel.
Yeah.
And some packaging tape.
And I folded a towel up, around my neck.
There you go.
And then I took
packaging tape and I taped the,
I made myself a neck brace.
Not looking up.
And Christy's like, calling
the physical therapist,
who's gonna come into the office
and has agreed to see me and make sure
that we're doing this right,
because when it was over,
I still didn't feel good.
I still felt really discombobulated.
But it wasn't spinning.
It wasn't spinning and then,
so a few hours later,
we're supposed to go in to see her,
but I thought that she
was coming to the house.
So I go downstairs.
The doorbell rings.
And, it's a,
I never met this therapist,
but it's an Asian lady.
I knew that.
Christy told me.
So, I go to the door with my neck brace on
and I open the door and
there's an Asian lady there.
And I say to her, I say,
"Thank you so much for coming.
"Please come on in."
And she said,
"Oh no, it's fine.
"I'll stay right here."
And I'm thinking, "You
can't do the maneuver on me
"right here."
But I didn't say that.
And then I saw that she had a name tag.
Right and she was--
And it said,
so and so, Judy so and so,
Forest Lawn Cemetery.
And she was trying to sell me
a grave plot.
And I'm like,
She heard about,
"Is it that bad?"
She heard
about the crystals.
Is it that bad?
We got a man with crystals.
You know what happens in
30% of the time.
My life is falling apart.
I open the door to get treatment
and a woman tries to sell me a grave plot.
Yeah.
And.
She's like, "Good he's got
on a towel neck brace."
I can barely stand
.
This is a good start.
He's close to death.
He's definitely at death's door.
I finally got rid of her.
And, I sat back down and we went
to the therapist.
Oh you didn't
buy a plot?
I didn't, I was like,
Forest Lawn is a classy place to go.
I'm like, "I wanna be incinerated."
But you can still,
but you can still have a
headstone.
I wanna
find like an environmentally,
most environmentally
friendly way to do it,
which may not exist yet, but.
That's a talk for another time.
Okay.
I go to the therapist,
physical therapist.
She was kind enough to see me.
And she did the same maneuver and it was,
Did it all again?
Yeah, but nothing was spinning.
But yeah, because you had
already done it.
And you know what?
What we did worked.
I was just so anxious and I believed that
it wasn't going to work,
that,
Do you know
what this reminds of?
I was just too uptight,
and that's what she told me.
And then she sold me a special pillow.
Oh she did?
Yeah, kind of like yours,
but different.
You know what,
I'm learning something
about you.
It had like husks
in it.
I'm learning
something about you.
Do you remember when you got
an Orbeez stuck in your ear?
I got an Orbeez in my left ear!
I can't get it out!
Yeah, it wasn't really an
Orbeez stuck in my ear.
There was for a moment.
Yeah, there was.
And then,
there was much consternation.
Because I believed it
was still in there, yeah?
Yeah, you've got a thing
about thinking that things
are still in your ear,
when they're not.
Listen, you're the hypochondriac.
I am, but,
When nothing's wrong with you,
you believe that the world is crumbling.
I'm not an acute hypochondriac.
But then when something is wrong with me,
and it gets better, I believe
that it hasn't gotten better.
Right, it's a different
type of hypochondria.
Okay, then that's it.
It's, that maneuver.
A shout out to Mr. And Mrs. Epley,
who invented that maneuver.
It's like magic.
Think about all the,
think about how they had to like,
I waited, I suffered
a day and a night
Did they do it with,
Not knowing about this maneuver.
Cadavers?
Like how did they figure it out?
Did they just look at the
ear and think about physics?
Yeah, it's awesome.
Now I got the rec this week.
It's really geometry,
I guess.
Rec,
baby rec, baby one, two, three, four.
I'll keep it simple.
My rec is,
remember the Epley Maneuver when the world
starts spinning around you,
because it's crazy that you can just,
Remember, or remember that it exists.
Just remember that it exists.
Yeah.
You don't even
have to learn it.
Just know that it's there.
It's a lot more complicated
than the Heimlich.
The Heimlich, don't watch a YouTube video,
when you need to do that.
Just do it.
Epley.
Epley you can take your time on.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
And also,
What other
maneuvers are there?
I recommend,
I recommend now, learning
the Heimlich Maneuver.
Let's all do that today.
What does it take to
come up with a maneuver?
Like, what would the McGlaughlin Maneuver,
or the Neal Maneuver be?
Because I feel like,
Well I have,
I got a,
What you have one?
I got a maneuver.
That's,
Again, it's a
love making maneuver.
It is okay.
Okay, so.
And we have to make a YouTube
video for it.
That's it, man.
I mean, it's crazy to be that scared
and that affected by something,
Yeah.
And then
just to sit in three different positions
and it get better?
Here's what I would've done, okay?
When it got better,
I would've been so relieved.
But when it was happening,
I would've thought that, "It's over."
I would've been like, "This is it.
"I got a tumor or something."
You know what I'm saying, like,
I immediately just jump to
the worst possible conclusion.
Right.
That's what my
hypochondria does.
And so,
I don't think that I
would've gone a full day
without going and seeing,
that night I would've been like,
"Jessie, we gotta go
to the emergency room."
I was just gonna sleep it off.
Yeah, I wouldn't have done that.
Couldn't have slept.
#EarBiscuits, let us know,
how your year's starting out.
Or whatever you want, however you wanna
respond to this.
And next week.
Yeah, we're getting into it
next week.
Whew.
Again, it's gonna be,
we're gonna talk about things we've never
talked about before.
That may or may not interest you.
But we're gonna talk about them.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.